it's time for a new generation of
leadership
Nikki Haley's announcement video betrays
her as the daughter of Indian immigrants
who achieves The American Dream by
becoming the first female governor of
South Carolina and then as a warrior for
American exceptionalism against Russia
China and Iran while serving as Donald
Trump's U.N Ambassador she argues her
relative Youth and her background will
inspire U.S voters to return to the
Republican Party Republicans have lost a
popular vote in seven out of the last
eight presidential elections that has to
change she's polling at under five
percent so it appears she's seizing the
chance to make a name for herself before
others enter the race a front-runner
against Donald Trump is Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis he isn't expected to
announce his candidacy until late May at
the earliest but after midterm elections
suggested Trump's popularity among swing
voters waning there are plenty of others
considering a run and as in 2016 the
more candidates that enter the primary
race the stronger the former president's
position is as the Republican anti-trump
voter splinters
for Haley the challenge is to appeal to
a republican base that is still solidly
behind Trump while also opposing Trump I
think uh folks love Trump and he's
somebody who people tend to be
especially the die hards all in but look
yeah if she's able to make the case that
I can take your the things that you that
are important to you the issues and and
the in the policies that are important
to you but you know package them a
little bit differently and I've got a
better chance to win in order to make
America great and glorious again I am
tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States Trump
himself has reminded his followers that
Haley had once pledged not to run
against him but he hasn't attacked her
clearly the bigger the field the better
for him Haley hasn't yet made much of an
impression on the Republican base but
she is a favorite among deep pocketed
Republican donors looking for an
alternative to Trump so she is likely to
have an impact although already there
are Whispers that ultimately it may be
on the race for the vice presidential
nomination in 2024 Shia britansi Al
Jazeera